are you aware of the charges that
Michael Jackson is currently facing yes
there and for the record these charges
hurt me the most
so he's guilty look man look Michael
Jackson has many faces
none of them look guilty to me he got
looking the eyes not the noses he was
critic used to this more than once so
some people say the cucumber's taste
better pickle what huh
what if I told you
the accusers correctly described
Michaels penis to investigators sir I
have never seen Michaels alleged penis
but I bet you that I could describe all
right let me guess there's a head a
shaft some balls
hair maybe pressed permed hair and
glitter spray that is correct I couldn't
pick my own penis out of a lineup all
right and me and my penis is like this
what about Michael saying it's okay to
have children sleeping I'm sure there's
plenty of kids asleep in the bed with
their those all the time and nothing
happens so do you think Michael Jackson
is guilty of the charges against him no
man he made Thriller
so you'd like your children's sleep with
it no are you aware that Robert Blake is
facing a charge of murder oh yeah
Loretta did that mr. Chappell are you
aware that Robert Kelley is being
charged with child pornography yes I've
heard of such things you've seen the
video right have I seen it like eighty
ten another part when he's waiting for
to come over he's looking in the camera
I think it was Robert Kelley on the tape
well I have to say was so then you
believe you urinated on a fifteen year
old girl Oh hold on lady I didn't say
all that you know what these tapes they
can do a lot of things fall I know that
piss was digital they think you're crazy
special effects look look check this out
I didn't even just do it
if his residual there do crazy stuff
expensive thing what about the girl
corroborating the story so what how much
money does this girl stand to make by
cooperating this store I tell you what
you give me that kind of money I'll
Kelly could fought in my dinner grateful
so besides the tape and the grow
corroborating the allegations what more
would it take for you to believe he's
guilty all right if I saw table all
Kelly paint on a girl while he was
singing pissing police officer was there
like four or five of my buddies and Neal
taking notes and his grandmother has to
be there to confirm his identity
[Applause]
mr. Chappell isn't that excessive no no
it's not excessive listen lady the burn
the proof is on the state on the state
you have got to prove to me beyond a
reasonable doubt whether or not this man
is a pisser aren't your doubts
unreasonable knows not unreasonable look
we're talking about a justice system
they have 500 people whose cases were
overturned by DNA evidence I've seen the
tape with five cops beat up a nigger and
then they said they had a reasonable
doubt I got my doubts too
all right how come you never found
digging two parts murder but then rest
Oh Jay the next date Nicole since you
can't rap
[Applause]
mr. Chappell you're dismissed